snapchat discover I don't know what that
is
I can only look at it once right but I
understand it's an app that you could
put on your phone and you can send it
messages to other people some connects
the whole world but I really don't know
snapchat so I'm here to learn it's gonna
take five quick photos so it make as
many goofy face faces as you can't ready
one two cool and so this whole baby
looks nuttin time yet and perfect and
then not now that's what they see you
like it
no I looks like a psycho do you know
what a dick thing oh I don't a dick pic
is I'm like turning red you can't just
like do a plain selfie usually you want
to like you know make it cool add
filters you have filters don't know
about filters okay so what will that do
if I pressed if I move that up or press
the T that'll just format the text so
it's nicer when I press the T at formats
the text not so when you're traveling
you want to like get us money geotags as
you can
what's a geotag okay so if you press on
the text again right here okay and then
you press these colors you can change
your color
oh it's purple that og ography ter hello
but make sure it's not ten seconds cuz
that's knowing I do seven I say ten
we're older people and our eyes have to
adjust and sometimes it takes a little
longer so now so now we'll draw on that
okay draw on top of it to noon and then
you can also add emojis or you could
really have fun all right I mean you
could write what everyone mm-hmm this is
one of the most fun things about
snapchat or the Facebook
so what you do is you press when you do
that and then you press down on your
face and it's gonna make that like thing
you can choose all these different
filters with your own it's like taffy
who ice as if I ooh yikes yikes okay so
now you're just talk and it's supposed
to be funny
oh it it worked with the a swab and
these things that you would want to use
in real life no I have to say I really
am very attracted snapchat really has so
much more application I thought it was
just you snapped on that little
funny-looking man and you saw a picture
basically getting your image out really
quick and getting that information out
to the world in terms of what you want
to say